Shure:  嗯楼上
Shure: Hmm, upstairs.
Jake:很中国很中国
Jake: Very Chinese, very Chinese.
Jake: 就是咱就不要做意大利面了
Jake: Let's not make spaghetti.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha: 原本有这个活原本有这个欢动吗 原本有这个活动吗
Tasha: Was this activity originally planned? Was this activity originally planned?
Jake:啊
Jake: Huh?
Jake: 有有做饭的活动
Jake: Yes, there was a cooking activity.
Jake: 没有做意大利面的活动
Jake: But no spaghetti-making activity.
Alice: 你们喜欢酸汤娃娃菜吗
Alice: 我很喜欢喝那个很鲜的
Alice: I really like drinking that flavorful one.
Jake: 那可以做一个
Jake: We can make one.
Jake:酸汤娃娃菜要做
Alice: 好你吃菇类吗菌类
Alice: Okay, do you eat mushrooms?
Tasha: 可以啊
Tasha: Sure.
Alice: 松花蛋你吃吗
Alice: Do you eat century eggs?
Tasha: 没吃过啊
Tasha: I've never had them.
Alice: 就是皮蛋
Alice: They're preserved eggs.
Alice: 黑的那个
Alice: The black ones.
Tasha: 也没吃过
Tasha: Never had them either.
Jake: 那好啊
Jake: That's good.
Tasha: 他长得好丑好丑呀
Tasha: They look really ugly.
Jake:是是 不想吃还是试一试吧
Jake: Yes, yes. Even if you don't want to, give it a try.
Tasha: 确实不想吃
Tasha: I really don't want to eat it.
Jake:可以试是吧
Jake: You can give it a try, right?
Tasha: 这长得丑可以丑
Tasha: This is really ugly.
Lucia: 我以为皮蛋是一个地域性菜系
Lucia: I thought century eggs were a regional dish.
Lucia: 就可能你们那边啊
Lucia: Like maybe from your area.
Alice: 有凉菜啊
Alice: It's a cold dish.
Lucia: 不过那个我也吃的很好
Lucia: But I also eat it well.
Alice: 只是你没有主动吃它
Alice: You just don't eat it on your own.
Alice: 啊对
Alice: Oh, right.
Alice: 不知道够不够
Alice: Not sure if it's enough.
Alice: 买几个吧
Alice: Let's buy a few.
Alice: 让我写上我写吧
Alice: Let me write it down.
Jake: 这是什么呀
Jake: What is this?
Tasha: 你猜
Tasha: Guess.
Jake: 打打面糊
Jake: Making a batter.
Tasha: 差不多吧可以
Tasha: Almost, yeah.
Shure: 打鸡蛋的那个
Shure: Beating eggs, right?
Tasha: 啊对
Tasha: Oh, right.
Jake: 鸡蛋是吧
Jake: Eggs, right?
Jake: 鸡蛋我看怎么会多一些
Jake: Eggs, I think we might need more.
Jake: 一样的是吧
Jake: The same, right?
Jake: 一口
Jake: Just one.
Shure:  但是看了是是这个
Shure: But it looks like this.
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Jake:哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Shure:  然后这么装上去哦
Shure: And then you put it on like this, oh.
Shure:  然后一按他就
Shure: Then you press it and it...
Jake:哦OKOK行
Jake: Oh, OK, OK, got it.
Lucia: 咱们这里要买
Lucia: We need to buy...
Jake:就是 你的描述
Jake: Right, your description...
Jake: 然后最后会兑现成一个现实
Jake: Then it will eventually become a reality.
Shure:  对让AI更了解我们人类
Shure: Yes, let the AI understand us better.
Tasha: 我知道啊
Tasha: I know, yeah.
Jake:对
Tasha: 对哦画画的时候会用到
Tasha: Yeah, we use it when drawing.
Lucia: 哦我以为是那
Lucia: Oh, I thought it was...
Lucia: 那种就是美缝用来对对对
Lucia: The kind used for tile grouting, right?
Tasha: 也可以再多买点别的水果
Tasha: We can also buy some more fruits.
Tasha: 装饰在蛋糕上
Tasha: To decorate the cake.
Lucia: 所以这个是那种
Lucia: So this is the kind...
Lucia: 就是画布旁边贴的那个
Lucia: That you stick next to the canvas?
Tasha: 对对对就
Tasha: Yeah, yeah.
Tasha: 是画纸上面贴的胶
Tasha: It's the tape you stick on the drawing paper.
Alice:调料再哪儿啊算了再来一个吧
Alice: Where are the seasonings? Forget it, let's get another one.
Tasha: 美文纸啊
Tasha: It's washi paper.
Lucia: 原来是我一直把它当成是一种胶带
Lucia: I always thought it was some kind of tape.
Lucia: 类似的东西
Lucia: Something similar.
Jake:什么纸
Jake: What kind of paper?
Tasha: 就是纸胶布嘛
Tasha: It's just paper tape.
Lucia: 对对对嗯
Lucia: Yes, yes, exactly.
Alice:胡椒
Alice: Pepper.
Lucia: 然后就反正我看到是那个东西
Lucia: Anyway, I saw that thing.
Lucia: 我就知道是他了
Lucia: I knew it was it.
Lucia: 但我不知道他叫什么
Lucia: But I didn't know its name.
Jake: 小厨房是吗
Jake: Is it the small kitchen?
Tasha: 对有点小
Tasha: Yes, it's a bit small.
Jake: 那桌子都给你
Jake: Then the table is all yours.
Jake: 那桌子都给你我们吃饭上去吃
Jake: The table is all yours, we'll eat upstairs.
Alice: 感觉喜欢喜欢那种森系的感觉吗
Alice: Do you like that forest-style vibe?
Tasha: 先放这吧好
Tasha: Let's put it here for now, okay?
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:楼上的厨房你觉得怎么样会大一点吗
Jake: How do you feel about the upstairs kitchen, is it bigger?
Tasha: 这两个规格不一样吗我感觉
Tasha: Aren't the two sizes different? I feel like...
Jake:不太一样那边那边会把这个给填起来
Jake: Not quite the same, that one would fill this space.
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Really?
Jake:要不上去
Jake: Wanna go up?
Tasha: 嗯不了不了不了算了
Tasha: No, no, no, forget it.
Alice: 没在那求过姻缘从不求
Alice: Never prayed for a marriage match, never.
Lucia: 这个是哪位宝宝的
Lucia: Whose baby is this?
Lucia: 好像也是某个电器的配件
Lucia: Seems like a part of some appliance.
Tasha: 嗯这是送的
Tasha: Yeah, it was a freebie.
Tasha: 没有这个好用
Tasha: Not as useful as this one.
Lucia: 啊那这个不是
Lucia: Oh, then this isn't needed?
Lucia: 反正不太需要是吧
Lucia: Not really necessary, right?
Lucia: 啊OK OK
Lucia: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 我把外面那个箱子稍微收拾一下
Lucia: I'll tidy up the box outside a bit.
Lucia: 那些不需要的我就扔掉了
Lucia: I'll throw away the unnecessary stuff.
Lucia: 这个配件先撂这吧
Lucia: Let's leave this part here for now.
Lucia: 说不定能用上
Lucia: Maybe we'll need it.
Lucia: 说明书
Lucia: The manual.
Jake:这不能控水吗
Jake: Can't this control water?
Lucia: 这个哎算了
Lucia: Oh, forget it.
Tasha: 应该没装电池吧
Tasha: Probably hasn't got batteries in it.
Lucia: 放在外面
Lucia: Put it outside.
Alice: 电池是不是在一个小
Alice: Is the battery in a small...
Tasha: 对在一个袋子里哎
Tasha: Yeah, it's in a bag.
Tasha: 那个袋子
Tasha: That bag.
Tasha: 嗯被扔掉了吗
Tasha: Hmm, was it thrown away?
Alice: 我记得刚才见到他了
Alice: I remember seeing it just now.
Alice:电子是吧
Alice: Electronic, right?
Tasha: 对是一个泡沫
Tasha: Yeah, it was in a foam.
Alice: 看有泡泡的那个是那个袋子
Alice: Look for the one with bubbles, that's the bag.
Alice: 所以那个袋子去哪了
Alice: So where did that bag go?
Jake: sorry已经没了
Jake: Sorry, it's gone.
Alice: 他长得很像垃圾会不会误扔掉了
Alice: It looked a lot like trash, could it have been thrown away by mistake?
Tasha: 他测的不准呀
Tasha: It's not accurate.
Jake: 啊 多少度
Jake: Ah, what’s the temperature?
Tasha:  27度哈哈哈哦哦
Tasha: 27 degrees, hahaha, oh oh.
Jake:哦我要死了 哈哈哈
Jake: Oh, I’m gonna die. Hahaha.
Tasha: 在上升
Tasha: It's rising.
Jake:多少
Jake: How much?
Alice: 他得有一个传递的
Alice: It needs to be transmitted.
Alice: 我看看
Alice: Let me see.
Jake:我的体感温度是吧这就是
Jake: My body temperature, right? This is...
Alice:三十多
Alice: Over thirty.
Jake:这么热
Jake: So hot.
Lucia: 这个可以不要了
Lucia: We can get rid of this.
Tasha: 好那他就是真的了
Tasha: Okay, so it's real then.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:哦有用是吧我多少度了三十多啊
Jake: Oh, it's useful, right? What’s my temperature now? Over thirty?
Alice:三十多
Alice: Over thirty.
Tasha: 他里面原本有一颗垫子
Tasha: It originally had a pad inside.
Tasha: 嗯那就够了
Tasha: Hmm, then that’s enough.
Lucia: 有剪刀或者之类的东西吗有剪刀
Lucia: Do you have scissors or something like that? Scissors?
Tasha: 剪刀在
Tasha: The scissors are...
Tasha: 这瓶水是我的吗
Tasha: Is this bottle of water mine?
Lucia: 呃应该是你的
Lucia: Uh, it should be yours.
Lucia: 这瓶水是我的
Lucia: This bottle of water is mine.
Lucia: 行可以拿笔在上面简单写一下
Lucia: Alright, you can use a pen to write on it, though it might rub off.
Lucia: 虽然有可能会被蹭掉
Lucia: Though it might rub off.
Lucia:  sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Jake: 1号线是吧
Jake: Line 1, right?
Tasha: 嗯你喝吗
Tasha: Hmm, do you want some?
Lucia: 便当啊这个
Lucia: This is a bento box.
Tasha: 我喝这个
Tasha: I'll drink this.
Tasha: 你不是不喝饮料吗
Tasha: I thought you don't drink beverages.
Alice: 这是我的
Alice: This one's mine.
Jake: 哈哈哈是喝饮料了啊
Jake: Hahaha, so you do drink beverages now!
Tasha: 哦呵呵呵
Tasha: Oh, hehe.
Jake: 是喝饮料了
Jake: So you do drink beverages.
Tasha: 杨老师写到累吗
Tasha: Jake, are you tired of writing?
Jake:不 不累
Jake: No, not tired.
Shure:  杨老师是Supersaya啊
Shure: Jake is a Supersaya.
Shure:  杨老师是超级赛亚人
Shure: Jake is a Super Saiyan.
Tasha: 赛亚人是什么意思
Tasha: What's a Saiyan?
Jake:赛亚人
Jake: A Saiyan.
Jake:一种不是人的不是
Jake: It's like a kind of non-human... non-human.
Shure:  5:20睡觉 13:14准时醒
Shure: Sleep at 5:20, wake up at 13:14.
Shure: 你这个9点准时醒有点反人类
Shure: Waking up at 9 is kind of anti-human.
Shure:  说实话哈哈哈哈
Shure: To be honest, hahaha.
Jake:那我是不是该快醒了啊我是不是快醒了啊还是已经醒了啊现在
Jake: So should I wake up now? Am I almost awake or am I already awake?
Tasha: 饿了什么时候吃饭
Tasha: I'm hungry, when's lunch?
Jake:几点了
Jake: What time is it?
Jake: 我是不是应该弄个钟买个钟买个表呢买个表
Jake: Should I get a clock? Buy a clock, or buy a watch? Buy a watch.
Tasha: 不知道他怎么放进去
Tasha: I don't know how he put it in.
Jake:今年买一个
Jake: I'll buy one this year.
Alice: 这下面有碗啊
Alice: There's a bowl underneath here.
Tasha: 哦你说哦
Tasha: Oh, you mean that.
Alice: 烤箱啊我以为你说要打这个哎
Alice: The oven, I thought you were talking about hitting this.
Alice: 要不然把这个打完
Alice: Or we could finish this.
Alice: 你吃了
Alice: You eat it.
Tasha: 这个盘还没洗好
Tasha: This plate isn't clean yet.
Shure:  这个用微波炉
Shure: Use the microwave.
Lucia: 这些都是有用的是吧
Lucia: These are all useful, right?
Shure:  有盘吧放盘里
Shure: There's a plate, put it on the plate.
Lucia: 嗯这些都是有用的
Lucia: Yeah, these are all useful.
Lucia: 这些用的
Lucia: These are usable.
Lucia: 嗯对我把这些那个就是没有用的
Lucia: Yep, I'll get rid of the useless ones.
Jake:哎呀什么掉了这什么呀
Jake: Oh man, what fell? What is this?
Lucia: 箱子就扔掉去
Lucia: Just throw the box away.
Lucia: 要不然感觉有点占地方
Lucia: Otherwise, it feels like it takes up space.
Tasha: 没有洒出来毕竟咱们皮
Tasha: Nothing spilled, after all, we...
Jake:烤鸡腿鸡皮
Jake: Roast chicken leg, chicken skin.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right
Lucia: 但是就是我觉得就留这种完整一点的
Lucia: But I think it's better to keep it more intact.
Lucia: 就行像这种就他比较烂的
Lucia: Like this, it's kind of bad.
Lucia: 或者说特别软的这种感觉
Lucia: Or if it's too soft, this kind of thing.
Lucia: 就可以不要了
Lucia: We can just discard it.
Tasha: 好了不用帮人家洗这么干净还要还的
Tasha: Alright, no need to clean it so thoroughly. They have to return it anyway.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Jake:比划一下
Jake: Show me.
Jake: 我这是自带的哦昨天的
Jake: I brought this myself, from yesterday.
Shure:  不是昨晚的吗
Shure: Wasn't it from last night?
Shure:  咱过日子就要有过日子的样子
Shure: If we're living our lives, we should look the part.
Jake: 咱环保环保过日子的人是吧咱都是
Jake: We're environmentally friendly people, right? We all are.
Jake:EGOlife都是过日子的人
Jake: Everyone here is living their lives.
Tasha: 你猜这个是用来干嘛的
Tasha: Can you guess what this is for?
Jake:哪一个我去
Jake: Which one? Oh, I see.
Tasha: 这个
Tasha: This one.
Jake:这不架子吗这是竖着
Jake: Isn't this a rack? It stands upright.
Tasha: 他是用来插烤鸡的
Tasha: It's for holding roast chicken.
Jake:妙啊然后它可以转
Jake: Brilliant! And it can rotate.
Tasha: 对啊在烤箱里转哦
Tasha: Yes, it rotates in the oven.
Jake:就这么转是吧哦哦
Jake: It rotates like this, right? Oh, oh.
Jake: 两边这么一插
Jake: You insert it on both sides.
Jake:真好玩
Jake: Really fun.
Jake: 学一学啊学一学
Jake: Let's learn how to use it.
Jake: 哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake: 有人打我电话看来是快递
Jake: Someone's calling me, probably the delivery.
Jake: 喂你好
Jake: Hello, hi.
Jake:哎好行稍等啊
Jake: Okay, sure, please wait a moment.
Jake:肯德基
Jake: KFC.
Jake:哦你好谢谢
Jake: Oh hi, thank you.
Jake: 哦我怎么弄
Jake: Oh, what should I do?
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Jake: 咱要不出去吃
Lucia: 在外边那个桌子那里吗
Jake: 昂行
Jake: Alright.
Jake:把这个伞给撑一撑
Jake: Open up this umbrella.
Jake:额这个把这个食物摆出来就结束好吧
Jake: Uh, let's just set up the food and we're done, okay?
Katrina: OK
Shure: 太他们爽了卧槽
Jake:哦那边已经断掉了已已经没有电了应该你要不看一下
Jake: Oh, it’s already off there. It seems to have no power. Can you check it?
Jake: 或者已经
Jake:storage已经没了
Jake:没有我看到你了你看到我了对吗可以看一眼
Jake: No, I can see you, you can see me, right? Take a look.
Jake:但是没关系对对对
Jake: But it's okay, yeah, yeah.
Jake:这怎么玩啊
Jake: How do you play this?
Jake:可以撑高一点
Jake: Can you raise it a bit?
Jake:看一下
Jake: Take a look.
Katrina: 啊有11点09
Katrina: 这是还在录还是什么录完了吧
Jake:我看一下啊
Jake: Let me check.
Shure: 有点太脏
Jake:太脏是吧
Jake: It's too dirty, right?
Shure: 或者我们可以买点一次性桌布在外面吃饭
Shure: 虽然不符合这个理念但是它很方便
Jake:哦是
Shure: 是吧
Katrina: 是不是充电宝没电了充电宝不亮了
Jake:你这还是有电不是知道刚刚怎么
Shure: 它可能累了罢工了
Shure: 发现我这个非常的稳定从来没有出过事故
Katrina: 那旁边邻居都是干啥的都是民宿吗
Katrina: 应该不是自己家住
Shure: 不全是
Katrina: 好安静啊特别像是在那种乡下来度假
Jake:这就是个乡下这就是个乡下
Katrina: 我北京二环也住过郊区也住过地地道道北京人
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Jake:嗯是二环那儿也挺破的
Jake: Hmm, the second ring road area is also quite shabby.
Jake:这里也挺破的
Jake: This place is quite shabby too.
Katrina: 挤过地铁吗
Katrina: 挤过
Jake:几号线
Jake: Which subway line?
Jake:一号线是吧你那边过来的吗
Jake: Line 1, right? Did you come from there?
Katrina: 好多我当时昌平也去过
Katrina: 我当时面北师北师昌平
Katrina: 然后北航在学院路那边
Katrina: 然后第三次来的时候去玩天安门
Katrina: 然后环球也玩了
Katrina: 然后颐和园也玩了
Shure: 这离环球近
Katrina: 都玩了还玩什么地方了
Katrina: 故宫反正都去过
Lucia: 就是光把就是离砸人这儿近的这部分擦一下
Lucia: Just wipe the part near where people sit.
Shure:  吃的不也放那儿吗
Lucia: 吃的尽量别挨着桌子呗
Lucia: Try not to put the food next to the table.
Katrina: 你愿意吃肯德基还是麦当劳
Shure: 麦当劳啊
Shure: McDonald's?
Lucia: 这个这个这个抹布要不咱放外面用
Lucia: How about we use this rag outside?
Jake:再再录一好行 再录一点点吧
Jake: Record another one, okay? Just a little bit more.
Jake:再说一个这个时间
Jake: Mention the time again.
Lucia: 我看里面还有新的到时候洗完或是干啥就用新的
Lucia: I see there are new ones inside, we can use the new ones after cleaning or something.
Jake:写一个1413把就好哇哦
Jake: Write down 1413, that would be good. Wow.
Lucia: 因为一个抹布的话感觉可能擦整个擦不干净所以我本来说光把边上大家用到的地方擦一下
Lucia: Because with one rag, it feels like we can't clean the whole thing properly, so I was thinking of just wiping the areas we use.
Jake:再拿一个抹布可以
Jake: Grab another rag.
Jake:一会儿可以再买点吧抹布
Jake: We can buy some more rags later.
Lucia: 这儿确实还有还有三
Jake:好用使劲用使劲用
Jake: Use it well, use it hard.
Lucia: 万一万一要洗碗的话 再弄谢谢 再弄新的
Jake:走
Alice: 今天是疯狂星期四的一半
Alice: Today is half of Crazy Thursday.
Katrina: 野餐呢
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: picnic day
Jake:可以
Jake: Alright.
Jake:Taco Tuesday
Jake:KFC Tuesday
Jake:疯狂星期二
Jake: Crazy Tuesday.
Katrina: 我手机在哪
Shure: 哎为什么你手机放我手呢
Katrina: 我不知道啊
Jake:这还一个旺仔牛奶
Katrina: 我喝旺仔牛奶
Jake:好勒
Jake: Got it.
Jake:我来我来搞一个你还剩多少
Jake: I'll handle this. How much do you have left?
Lucia: 没事没事没事
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Lucia:差不多刚才那个硕就是把这边已经擦了一遍了
Lucia: I just wiped this area a moment ago.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 有时候反应不过来他的全名这个名字还挺好记得
Lucia: Sometimes it's hard to react quickly to his full name, but it's actually easy to remember.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Lucia: 咦真挺脏的这凳子是不是也得也得啊小心
Lucia: Ew, it's really dirty. Should we also be careful with this chair?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 让我看看这凳子脏不脏
Lucia: Let me check if this chair is dirty.
Jake:这东西移不走啊我还想把这空出来多一个位置
Lucia: 好啦凳子也挺脏的
Lucia: Okay, the chair is pretty dirty too.
Jake:这个是闻所未闻的肯德基啊长成这个样子
Jake: This is unheard of, a KFC looking like this.
Jake:这肯德基烤鸭
Jake: This is KFC roast duck.
Jake:肯德基披萨
Jake: KFC pizza.
Jake:这真的是能笑话外国人
Jake:他们点的肯德基是什么东西
Jake:我们的肯德基是什么东西
Jake:对他们的肯德基只有汉堡就是现在还是那老五样
Jake: Their KFC has nothing new, still the same old stuff.
Alice: 这是中式的有骨有骨鸭
Alice: This is Chinese-style boned duck.
Lucia: 对肯德基和麦当劳的新品好像国内外是不太一样的
Lucia: Yeah, the new items at KFC and McDonald's are quite different between here and abroad.
Alice:有骨鸭米花
Alice: Boned duck nuggets.
Tasha: 呃口感也不一样
Tasha: Uh, the texture is different too.
Jake:对对
Katrina: 夹那种什么辣的辣味酱那种
Jake:就是国内的肯德基麦当劳比国外卷多了和国内一样
Jake: The KFC and McDonald's here are more competitive than those abroad, just like everything else here.
Jake:坐坐开
Jake: Take a seat.
Alice: 哎是不是凳子不太够
Alice: Hey, are there enough chairs?
Tasha: 正好6个
Tasha: Exactly six.
Jake:搬搬那边去
Jake: Move them over there.
Alice: 没擦吧
Alice: Haven't wiped them?
Jake:没擦擦一下吧
Jake: Haven't wiped them, wipe them down.
Alice: 抹布在哪
Alice: Where's the cloth?
Lucia: 这这四个都擦过了刚才那另外的还没来得及擦
Lucia: These four have been wiped already, but I haven't had time to wipe the others yet.
Jake:起
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 停吗
Shure: Should we stop?
Jake:停吧吃汉堡咱就不拍了吃汉堡这个不太重要
Jake: Yeah, let's stop. We don't need to film eating burgers, that's not too important.
Jake:眼镜我放进去吧别在这儿晒坏了
Jake: I'll put my glasses away, don't want them to get damaged in the sun.